we wondered if they would do it we
wondered how they would justify it and
now we are starting to figure out
exactly how the first steps of blocking
Donald Trump's tax returns from being
released or going to work and step one
is that the US Treasury led by Steven
minuchin is just saying we're not going
to release Trump's tax returns to
congressman Richard Neal to go back a
few days congressman Richard Neal from
Massachusetts used a the authority of a
1924 law which allows any House or
Senate committees that are involved in
tax writing to request and really it's
more than request to demand the tax
returns of individuals from the United
States Treasury and the immediate
question with a deadline of the end of
this week was is Treasury Secretary
Stephen minuchin going to deny it is he
going to simply let the deadline expire
is he going to release the tax returns
and the US Treasury has in the immediate
denied this request last night Treasury
secretary Stephen minuchin who of course
was handpicked by Donald Trump as most
Treasury secretaries are that's not an
unusual thing but it's important to bear
it in mind when we're talking about the
tax returns of the president put out a
letter saying he needs more time to
consider whether he is going to release
Trump's tax returns and this could
become a massive massive legal battle
because at some point if minuchin says
his final decision is know that he's not
releasing the tax returns despite the
fact that you can call the law arcane
you can call it whatever you want but it
is the law and this is something that
House and Senate committees that are
involved in tax writing can do he is
going to have to legally justify why he
is not releasing Donald Trump's tax
returns to the House committee not
publicly minuchin said quote the legal
implications of this request could
affect protections of all Americans
against politically motivated
disclosures of personal tax information
regardless of which party is in power
now
that might sound reasonable you might
hear that and say hey yeah you know we
don't want there to be a really easy way
to have people's taxes requested
obtained for merely political reasons
but it's not really a reasonable
explanation from Stephen minuchin number
one is that there is a legal basis for
this request from Richard Neil okay it's
based on a 1924 law that is very binary
it says nothing about the Treasury
secretary gets to evaluate and decide
whether a particular request is
political further whether a request for
taxes is political is completely
subjective in nature it is often or it
is clearly in the eye of the beholder
but the one part here that I admit is
not in the favor of Democrats is that
legal experts believe even if you put
aside whether the request is political
in nature legal experts are mostly
United around the idea that there has to
be some defensible legislative reason to
see Donald Trump's taxes okay the House
and Senate are political bodies so in
some sense everything they do is
political in nature and that's not
really a fair standard to apply but
there is a very reasonable question
which is is there a legislatively
defensible reason why Richard Neil's
committee Richard Neal deserves or or is
reasonable is reasonably in a position
to request and want to see Donald
Trump's taxes you can say well
suspicions of financial crimes by Donald
Trump is a pretty damn good reason but
we don't know if they actually have the
evidence to make that case beyond a
reasonable doubt and also in a way that
trumps Treasury secretary Stephen
minuchin would find motivating or
convincing and ultimately once again it
might end up being a decision made by
courts and that's probably not good news
for Democrats especially when the
highest court in the land the Supreme
Court has been completely taken over by
Trump appointees partially thanks to
Mitch McConnell blocking Barack Obama's
nomination of Merrick garland to the
Supreme Court one year before the 2016
election so all of this stuff
is related this all you know there's no
way to just talk about Richard Neal's
request without talking about the
broader sort of context that is at play
here one legal expert Thomas hungar
who's the former general counsel for the
House of Representatives said quote this
is uncharted territory and as I've said
before I want to see the returns the
returns should be released it shouldn't
become a legal battle for the President
or a candidate to the presidency to
release their tax returns but if you are
waiting around for evidence of
criminality from Trump's tax returns I
just don't see it and I know I've said
this a bunch of times now but I think
it's important just to mention it every
time so in six months I'm not misquoted
and get a hundred angry emails about it
the most likely scenario for me is
number one Trump is not nearly as
wealthy as he claims to be he's an
egomaniac he doesn't want that to be
known which it potentially would be via
the release of his taxes
number two Donald Trump pays a
pathetically low effective federal tax
rate which again I don't know how much
of a concern that is for him because he
said that that makes him smart he tries
to legally pay as little in taxes as
possible which most people do and his
base wouldn't punish him for paying very
little in taxes anyway so that is a sort
of 50/50 and then if you're expecting
criminality I say just forget about it
get ready to vote in 2020 and let's get
this guy out of office if you disagree
with me if you think that there could be
or is likely to be evidence of
criminality and Donald Trump's tax
returns I want to hear from you and I
want to hear from you about exactly what
crimes you believe could be exposed by
Donald Trump's taxes and if you're gonna
say money laundering to Russians for New
York real estate that's not going to be
on Donald Trump's personal taxes and
it's questionable whether it would even
be outlined so specifically in Donald
Trump's corporate taxes but I want to
hear from you either way I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman the show is on twitter at
david pakman show one of today's
sponsors is a company I'm really excited
about because they're big supporters of
progressive media but it's also a
service I've actually been used
for a while in my personal life it's a
language learning service called
linguist and they're letting our
audience try it out for free you don't
even have to enter your credit card
number just go to linguist comm slash
Pakman Ling this was created by one of
the physicists who discovered the Higgs
boson and he designed linguist to help
himself and others learn languages as
efficiently and thoroughly as possible
using artificial intelligence and
machine learning algorithms and that's
what makes linguist so different from
all of the other language learning apps
out there linguist has used billions of
data points from its learners to figure
out how the human brain actually works
when it's learning a language and
storing memories it mixes new words that
you haven't seen yet with the words you
still need to repeat and the magic
happens when it spaces these repetitions
refreshing a word at just the right
moment so that you don't waste any time
in your learning process it's fast it's
simple there's no fluff no crazy verb
conjugation charts you have to memorize
it's just elegant and proven to be one
of the most efficient ways to learn a
language and it also has voice
recognition capabilities which is super
convenient especially when you're using
the app on your phone go try it on your
browser or mobile device see for
yourself it's available in Spanish
French German and Russian if you're
trying to learn one of these four
languages and you're looking for an
evidence-based method to take your
skills to the next level you should
check it out and you can do it totally
free like I said no credit card required
to try it out just click the link
underneath this video